how you doing man so uh so we've got a
little girl
inside and um her mom was here earlier
she looks just like her mom which is
like immediately when she came in she
came in after we Clos she walked up to
the door and she was immediately welcome
cuz like why is there a little kid here
cuz I I actually got on my seat and I
was like brought their kid to a bar this
thing and I realized she's just missing
she just doesn't know her mom is that's
our
we' got a little girl inside her name
is mom's name is
Victoria um I've tried calling her mom
several times I've actually tried asking
her last names and going on Facebook and
finding maybe trying to find mutual
friends I've tried everything guys
what's the how'd you get the phone
number she's actually a regular here she
actually used to work here a long time
ago the girl's mom MH okay um but
that's that's that's it but I mean I I
have I have tried everything you have
address for I don't okay um you don't
have her last
name no okay I think probably the little
girl does I I think I I had the the
dad's last name I have a a solid phone
number so I didn't ask for the last name
I got all
right can I have your
names
H CH Chris Matt who's who one talking to
I'll be talking to Matt Chris
Chris where's uh
my friends they're
Heroes Chris how you doing I like a
little
pumpkin yeah okay where' you walk from
um I walk from my car over there all
right this is on you guys out right it's
okay can tell us where you came from
from okay you want to sit in that comfy
Booth with them you want to sit with
them it's okay where ice
cream it melted it melted you let it you
let it just melt all the
way what's your mom's
name um her name is
Veronica Veronica what was the last name
roxan B Belle okay name was her last
name is you're awesome at this where's
your mommy at sit next to me if you need
to okay you don't know you said you
walked from your car yeah because um she
I fell asleep during it and then she
hasn't been there ever since cuz we um
got there and like and then and then I
my mom said it wouldn't be wrong and
then she
um after like 5 to 10 minutes she she
just haven't came back okay where is
your car around here somewhere um yeah
it's over there I can show you it yeah
let's do that easy way to solve this run
the tag on the car get mom's name get
Mom's address emergency contact walk
with you I will walk with you if that's
okay can I walk with her yeah of course
we're doing super yeah you're doing
so going to show us here
okay I'll be there
I'm around here it's okay you show us
wherever it is
okay these guys are just helping us okay
okay you tell them anything that you
feel like you need to tell
them and SK
boy phone you found SC Del get her the
phone in there okay oh yeah
myom she left her phone
inter that light over there yeah is that
yeah those are the keys it's the
keys
okay do you want to give it to this
s yeah he's going to help us out okay
want you he can maybe be in any of these
buildings okay she walked off to one but
I can't see where because she turned the
lights off okay does this ever happened
before um no she never leaves the car
without me no she saided something
really important and she said it would
be a real quick when it hasn't because
it like was like 5 to 10 minutes which
way did you say she walked um I couldn't
see because she turned the the lights
off every single one okay okay but you
don't remember which way she walked when
she left the car
no
okay got some for your mom when she get
back okay so we want to thank Morgan and
Morgan for sponsoring this video I think
it's pretty clear from the stories that
we cover that it's not always safe out
there when you're hurt it can be pretty
confusing it can be scary you don't know
where to turn well Morgan and Morgan is
actually the largest injury law firm in
America and at a time when you already
have so much to think about they make it
super easy for you they've completely
modernized the process because you
submit your claim you sign contracts you
upload documents and you talk to your
whole legal Team all on your phone
that's it an attorney's going to review
your case in just eight clicks also they
have 4,000 support staff that can help
you through the process too which is
just amazing to think about and in terms
of price you only pay them if you win
there's no upfront fee so if you're
injured you want to join the over three
million people that call them every year
you can submit a claim at www.
forthepeople.com law on crime or by
dialing pound law that's pound 529 on
your
phone there were people around
but I thought it was just a car but now
I can see that's a campfire so the
campfire was there when you first got
here um yeah okay but there was only a
little bit of it I
gotta were you able to see the people
around the campfire no no the bus is
blocking it bus is blocking
it
Okie
dogs you're doing so good if she'd walk
down here she would never leave me
because this she's never done anything
like this before but but that's blocked
off so she can't go that
way 10 minutes and then I found Skydive
the land I heard people talking I follow
a bit and I went inside okay you came to
hang out with us right because the car
was off completely minutes good an hour
maybe an hour maybe okay you thinking
more than an hour or less than an hour
no I think right around an hour okay I
don't I don't think it was a ton more
than that right around an hour for
sure we had her some food
and then it was kind of like yeah she
was living good what do we
do good thing you called thank you you
doing good mhm okay you want to hold my
hand still
okay um she has a purse that goes around
here and it's like um to here and then
she wears it right mostly around here or
here and then she has her phone in it
but she didn't bring her phone right
what was her shirt maybe do you know
what was it like pink purple like long
sleeved white long sleeved white white
was she wearing pants um no no what was
she wearing um she was wearing a long
sleeve shirt and then she wore um she
wore some shorts wore some shorts like
shorts like me um yeah like this like
little shorts tight shorts yeah okay and
a long sleeve white I know shirt I know
when I I'll see her
because he
[Music]
knows
founder multiple questions Jason's set a
minute out so I'm assuming he's still
coming she uh was heading back to her
car to get her daughter where
from
um another
which
car um over
there
okay you
realize it's 6:30 in the morning right I
I do now and you realize that your
daughter seven yes 7 years old has been
by herself with
us for four for 4 hours I do
know you doing you know you understand
my frustration with this whole situation
right what on God's green earth were you
doing that your daughter is here by
herself at 7 years old where she's
terrified and goes into the bar and asks
random bar people to help and call the
police I have no idea I'm
sorry sorry ain't going to cut
it she said she was in a car somewhere
over there okay can you show us yes
a second one or the
first in that go hang out can you guys
just kind of keep an
eye read the car
alone so wait you were in the car alone
yes whose car is it I have no idea why
were you in someone's car you don't even
know I have I have no
idea you understand how this works right
I do what's your drug of choice my my
drug of choice is alcohol but like I I I
don't know how I ended up in the car I
just woke up in the car honestly how'd
you end up here um I I came here to meet
friends yeah so like all I all I know is
I I came here to meet friends um and
then I I woke in the car yeah r on I
came here to meet my friend R non and
then I woke up in that car that's all I
know I I I really didn't mean to me
leave my seven-year-old alone in in the
car I would never do such a thing I
mean her dad died last year he was
murdered he was stabbed in in in the in
the
um like I would never try to leave my
seven-year-old alone so when you met
your friends here ran yes when you met
ran here did you go into the bar yes
absolutely okay did you have a drink
yes what was the last thing you remember
the last thing I remember is me and my
friend run on here and then having a
drink and that's it but like I mean I'm
not an alcoholic you know what I mean
like I
I I can hold my drink like I'm I'm 35
years old I mean like that was probably
like my third drink you know what I
mean so
um it shouldn't have knocked me out but
do you feel I don't know why I was in
that
car now I'm not a woman and I don't know
how
things do you feel like maybe you were
violated in any way
I don't know
like I woke up in a car that wasn't mine
I woke up in a situation where I I
didn't know where I was at um were your
clothes on my clothes were on yes um my
clothes were buttoned yes um but
um I don't know how I ended up like this
you know what I mean like I shouldn't
have ended up like this I've never been
this oh you're right it shouldn't have
ended up like this right
right also probably shouldn't have come
up here with your seven-year-old right
well I just came up here to to say hi to
my friend have a drink and then leave
but like obviously it didn't turn out
that way you know what I mean so you
said you had three drinks yes what is it
that you drink um I drink
beer yes so I had two beers um before I
came here I had a beer when I
got
so yeah I I don't know how I got from
two beers before here and then one
beer I had one beer here where I'm
getting at when's the last time you saw
Ram
um I mean obviously it's been several
hours like were you sitting at the bar
together and then next thing you know
you're waking up in the car or no like
you go to the bathroom like I don't I
don't remember anything from tonight
like this is what I'm getting
like um like tonight is very
hazy but as as far as being here I don't
mind getting
here I mean yeah in a sense because I
only had two beers you know what I mean
but other than that
no well you stated that you came here to
meet
friends and then you remembered going
into the you do remember coming here yes
yes so let's be honest okay yeah I'm
that's going to be the best way for this
situation okay because you just left
your seven-year-old daughter alone for 6
hours right you understand that right I
understand that so let's be honest with
us when we ask you questions you answer
them completely and truthfully all right
all
right so after you left the
bar what happened not after I left the
bar after I left City Limits um after
you left city limits yes tonight yes
when were you at city limits tonight
before they came here before they came
here yes okay yes um I met my friend ran
here and then I got is ran a male or a
female male a male we've talked
ran
okay
so um with uh you don't remember you
don't remember leaving at all like from
here no
okay um how long have you known
Ron um probably for like I would say
four five months what's your guys's
relationship we're friends did you guys
hook up make out do any of
that
benefits
um excuse me um
so the very last thing you remember do
you remember where you were standing
over here no no
um so what's your what's your last
memory at this bar you like location
like where you inside outside I remember
coming to this bar meaning we're on so
you just remember showing up and then
boom it was done how much did you have
to drink before you came here uh two
beers two beers any prescription drugs
no the boxing yes you took some boxing
yes how much you take um one strip a day
okay you going to take anything else no
is it prescribed yes
so with your what kind of beer was it
that you drank
um it was I would say equivalent to a
Yingling yling so um was it a draft
bottle draft okay um aside from
obviously what you're telling us is you
don't remember all you remember showing
up meeting her on and and then that's it
from here um who beside your daughter
were you at city limits with it just
your daughter you guys Wen having dinner
with anybody else or anything like that
no sir okay
um all right
um
so you you met ran was it out here or
was it inside it was inside he was
already here waiting on you yes he
already here did he have your beer
waiting for you when you got here no or
you ordered it when you got here that
was that when I got and then from the
time that you got handed your beer did
you ever leave that beer unintended go
to the bathroom or do whatever
yes yes
sir yes superly
yes he lived here my whole life um I'm
35 years old I grew up in land
and this is the place that I
trust have you ever used in the past I
have um I'm an ex IV addict um but uh
I've been sober now from IV drugs for 5
years when was the last time you
used it's been 5 years it's been 5 years
M so you didn't know D back in
January
January of this year that there's a
vucha County Sheriff's Office report
about yes I AB did okay so the last time
you used was January yes okay so again I
don't understand why we're
Ling because a lot of a lot of these
questions we asking you we we know some
of the answers to we're trying but the
behavior the behavior that I've done is
years we're not talking about the
behavior we're talking about your
actions understand so understand so you
can see where the level of distrust is
right right cuz you know we're not we're
not kids in the block I mean he kind of
is but he's he's smarter than the
average could be right yes sir so we're
not fucking around here because a
seven-year-old was left by herself to
walk into a bar of strangers who could
have been the most god- awful people on
the planet but thankfully they've been
nothing but Angels the entire time they
have devoted their time since she came
in the bar to make sure that this
traumatic experience does not become a
severely traumatic experience yes sir
okay understand so this is what we're
trying to figure out right now is just
what happened because like we've been
telling you we've been searching for you
for 6 hours right I mean cuz even before
we got BR we got brought into all this
they've been trying to blow up your
phone and get in contact with you at
least an hour or so before they even
called us right right so
this is a very serious situation yes sir
okay so
obviously you
know if something if you were the victim
of something obviously we will address
that and go forward from there right
however right now your daughter in a way
is also victimized because she
absolutely because she was she was left
here to her own devices in a car that
had not clearly been running for a long
time which luckily it's the middle of
the night cuz it was the middle of the
day she yes sir okay
so you may may have been sober from
those hard drugs 5 years ago or I guess
January alcohol doesn't it's it's not
that much different okay cuz i' I have
my brother who heroin addict for 20
years he would drink he would still
smoke weed fall back right back into it
every time now if you're one of the few
that don't go back to it again alcohol
is just another another Avenue right
okay
so this
this is a very serious situation all
right um not only could I
mean like you said the people in there
were nice right had they not been nice
somebody could have been like you know
what I'm going to help you find your mom
come get in my car let's go you know
what then you never see your daughter
again yes sir probably sold on a black
market to become a a a whore or a
freaking you know a slave of some sort
you know or dead we could have just
found her in that ditch down there right
but we were looking for
you understand no honesty goes a long
way most certainly if you're 100% clear
you know you're not I just hooked a guy
up yesterday you know who was honest
with me and said you know what I got
some heroin here I got some boxing here
I got some needles here right so I took
care of him guess what he went to jail
but he didn't get pounded like he could
have got pounded because he was
honest you're facing possible charges of
child neglect child
endangerment fin understand all I'm
there's a lot of stuff that'll take her
away from you yes sir that's so you
won't see her
anymore even when you get out of prison
her her her dad was murdered last year
you know and it's had a huge effect on
me you know what I mean um and I wish
tonight was different and I'm sorry to
hear that he was murdered but she's got
to be your priority absolutely you're
absolutely right I
but you know it's not going to change
the
tonight is the reason you're wearing
long
sleeves um this that's cold drink when
was the last time you used um the last
time we used it January would you mind
rolling up your sleeves well certainly
sure
is there any particular reason why you
left your daughter and did not bring
your phone with
you um I just wanted to go see a friend
real quick honestly and then it it it
turned into me being inebriated and not
being able to function all right before
we go any further yes sir I do this with
everybody because we ask questions and
stuff like that okay doesn't necessarily
mean you're going to jail doesn't
necessarily mean that but I just want to
show you your rights okay so you have
the right to remain silent and anything
say may be used as you as evidence
against you yes sir you have the right
to talk to an attorney and have him or
her present with you now or at any time
during questioning if you cannot afford
an attorney one will be appointed to
represent
you if at any time you wish to stop
talking or have an attorney present all
questioning will be stopped at your
request do you understand these rights
yes sir all right with these
rights um with these rights in mind do
you want to keep talking to us of course
okay thank you I just I mean your this
is for your protection and art okay so
it's just
to you know just to protect you and in
your rights because if we ask you
questions and you lie well now you just
committed purgy right okay we ask you
questions and you tell us something that
lead us to see that you're a victim of
something which is what I was trying to
allude to earlier when I was asking you
those questions to see if maybe you are
a victim of something I've never
somebody drugged you or something like
that I've never been okay this three
drinks so have no idea trying to give
you the benefit of the doubt yes sir all
right because me as a parent I have a
son and I would never in my right mind
anything like that I mean I have a GCF
case you know what I mean like I would
never you know what I mean but
I I honestly officer I I have no idea
how I got to this point literally you
know like what w me up as girl Bright
Lights you know like I I've never been
like I mean all I drank was beer I had
three
beers so I remember getting here I
remember having a beer and then that's
it I don't know how to look up in a car
that looks like mine and it's very
similar to
mine um
and leaving my daughter you know it was
supposed to be just a very brief
interaction and now I supposed to
walk and
then I have to ask yes sir not wearing
any shoes which is fine I mean people
don't no Sho on but your clip Toops are
in your car so did you go into the bar
with no shoes on uh I mean I had to have
um but like I said it was supposed to be
a very brief interaction and I supposed
to go home I mean I've never been in
this bar I don't know how it is